I think bandages are great.
They make me feel warm inside.
Commander, are we playing red light, green light?
I'll protect you, Commander.
Commander, Rappi, Anise, Neon, you're all the best!
I think bandages are great.
They make me feel warm inside.
Commander, Rappi, Anise, Neon, you're all the best!
Awaiting your command.
Danger is always around the corner.
Commander, how about you, Yumi, and I have some fun?
I like to have my body do the talking.
Commander, how about you- I don't believe there are enough viewers here.
I'm so beautiful today.
I like it.
Oh?
Did you need something?
I'm a bit preoccupied admiring myself in the mirror right now.
Just give in to it and free yourself.
Commander, how about you, Yumi, and I have some fun?
I don't believe there are enough viewers here.
I'm so beautiful today.
I like it.
I don't believe there are enough mirrors here.
Hello, everyone!
Hello, hello!
Welcome!
Oh, let me put this image on first.
Whoa!
Welcome, everybody!
I was just, you know, I was waiting, you know?
I just wanted to see what they'll say.
But welcome, everybody, to a Rare Doki Twitch stream!
Let's go!
Also, thank you for the five gifted subs, Marco!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it, guys!
So, today is a special stream, if you guys don't know.
It is Nikkei 2.5 Anniversary, and whenever they have a special event, you know you're gonna see a Doki bird!
It's actually crazy that it's been 2.5 years since Nikkei first came out.
It does not feel like this... I don't know.
It feels like this game has been out for a while now, but it's only been 2.5 years.
And, like, we've been doing sponsors for Nikkei since the early access.
So, it's actually crazy to think about that.
It's, like, tradition now.
Like, every time there is a special event, I'll be here.
They hit me up for a sponsor to check out all the newest updates that it has to offer.
So, yeah!
Welcome, everybody!
So, also, if you guys don't know, it's pinned on the chat.
And also, there's, like, a little Nightbot is also doing a little timer thing.
But I should also... I should make a command right now.
Like, give me a sec.
Let me make a Nightbot command.
Where I made, like, a timer for it to, like, remind me.
But I believe... Let me see if I do this correctly.
Let's see.
Advanced settings.
All right.
Uh...
Let's do Nikkei.
Okay, do an exclamation point...
Oh, wait, never mind.
Never mind.
Apparently, the command was already made.
Wait, it wasn't.
All right.
Let me make it right now.
Whoa!
I'm a professional!
All right.
Command will be Nikkei.
And then it would say...
What would it...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
Sorry.
I knew I forgot something.
I knew it.
There's always one thing I forgot.
All right.
Let's make it so that we have, like, a 10-second cooldown for this.
So, if you use the command Nikkei, it will give you a link to, you know, my special link.
Where if you click it, you can get...
And you sign up for it.
You can get up to 160 free draws slash pulls.
Which is a lot if you think about it.
That gives you, like, you know, because, like, you can do 10 pulls.
Um, you have to progress the story, though.
If you wish to get more of the free pulls.
But it is a lot of pulls if you think about it.
Because, like, you can basically get, like, some of your, like, dream characters within, um...
Within, like, less than 100 pulls.
Um, if you're...
If you don't have bad luck like me recently.
Ahahaha!
But it's all gonna change today!
Today is where it's gonna change!
I will finally get the good characters!
Cause...
What was it?
What was that character I was trying to get last time?
That...
I end up...
I may not have gotten the other character from the two year.
I might not have gotten Asuka.
But!
I got someone better than Asuka!
Hahahaha!
I might not have gotten her!
But I got someone better.
Ha ha!
I got..
I got blue Asuka!
hahahahaha!
Asuka, that's right.
Sorry, Asuka...
I got- I got someone better!
Anyway, sorry.
Um, every time I tab out of the game.
Like, she starts talking.
Our time into the game.
So that's what you heard.
Anyway, I got... You're right.
I got Modernia.
That's so much better.
That's who I... That's right.
You guys want to... That's right.
I got her.
Wait, no, that's Mihara.
I got... Where is she?
Where is she?
I got her.
See?
Asuka couldn't say that.
Look at that.
Oh my god, thank you.
Look, she called me the best, guys.
Wait... You don't need to see her.
You don't need to see her, chat.
All you have to do is hear her.
It's only for my eyes.
Anyway, so if you guys don't know, for the 2.5 year anniversary, they did release a new character called, I believe, the Little Mermaid.
And it's actually really funny because the dev... The staff, the devs, during, like, the sponsor briefing was like, she's broken.
And, um... So, they're like, you can tell, chat, that she's incredibly broken right now.
So, apparently, uh, Little Mermaid is incredibly strong.
And she surpasses some character named Lita.
Lita, I believe.
And, like, uh, you guys might know who she is.
I don't.
I just know by what they look like.
Um, but she is considered the strongest anniversary character, um, that's ever been launched.
So, um... So, she is incredibly busted.
And we're gonna see if we can get her.
And which we will, guys.
I swear to God.
I... We will not have a repeat of what happened last time.
We will get her this time, chat.
We... We are... We are gonna actually get the anniversary character.
My luck changes today.
I make my own luck.
Guys, it changes here.
Anyway, there's also, apparently, there's, um...
Uh...
What the fuck?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
I had a video play.
I was like, what the fuck?
Okay.
I had, like, a short playing in the background.
I was like, who's talking to me?
But you guys didn't hear.
Um... Also, there's, like, a lot of other new updates.
Since it is an anniversary update, there's a lot of other stuff.
So, apparently, Mihara got ascended into SSR.
Um... And they released a...
They released a free character, which you can get.
Which is Mori.
And she's also an SSR character.
And she's apparently free right now.
So, yeah.
If you guys want an SSR character without doing any pulls, this is the right time to get them now, during the anniversary.
And, like, all anniversary updates, they also give you free pulls.
So, like I said, there is...
Um...
There is a free...
There's up to 160 free pulls that you can get.
And, of course, there's, like, new character...
New skins.
Uh...
Reruns of limited skins that you're looking to get those.
And also, new stories.
Apparently, there's, like...
I realized that since this game's been out for 2.3...
Yeah, we all love free stuff, guys.
Like, come on.
Don't you guys want free stuff?
Free pulls.
I didn't realize that because this game has been out for 2.5 years, there's, like, 30-plus chapters now.
Like, obviously, every new update, they add, like, a new chapter for the game.
And, um...
Guess what chapter I'm on?
I'm gonna get there eventually.
The amount of times they sponsor me...
Eventually, I will get to that chap...
I will get to chapter 30.
I am...
No, I'm actually on...
I'm actually halfway through chapter 4, guys.
Um...
I'm actually halfway through chapter 4.
Eventually, I will get to chapter 30.
I...
I'm almost caught up, guys.
I'm almost there.
Um...
Anyway...
So, obviously, because it is a new update, they do have other stuff, like, um...
New...
New event story with...
The Little Mermaid.
And there's also, like, a new minigame called Bubble March.
And, yeah.
So, they recently released chapter 37 and chapter 38.
So, we're eventually there.
Yeah.
By the 30th anniversary, I will catch up by then.
Uh...
Yeah.
I heard the minigame was really fun.
Like...
Apparently, you guys can, like, play with me in a way.
I'm not sure yet.
Because, obviously, I haven't tried it out.
We're all experiencing it live right now.
But, um...
And, like, I said, like...
I think, like, Nike is also...
Has a really...
Really a good...
Uh...
Good story.
Like, with new character...
Character development and story-wise.
Um...
People kept telling me that...
The longer you play...
Um...
The more...
The more sad you'll get.
Because they're...
Because the story is actually really, really good.
So, I hope by the 30th anniversary of Nike...
I will be able to get to chapter 30.
Like, I will get to chapter 30.
I...
We will get there.
Eventually.
We...
Alright.
So...
Before we actually...
Uh...
Try out the game.
We do have several videos that...
Um...
They sent me to watch.
That's related to the anniversary.
Uh...
So, yeah.
Let me...
Let me get that.
I'll need sound...
Sound guy.
Is sound guy here?
I need to know.
Is sound guy here right now?
Because...
Uh...
I don't know if the video is loud enough.
Okay.
Nice.
I see you.
I see you, sound guy.
Alright.
Let's check up...
Let's check up the...
Uh...
Anniversary videos.
And see how...
Let's see what...
It's gonna give us.
There's like three different videos too.
So...
Woop.
Whoa.
What should we do today?
Oh, is that Little Mermaid?
Is that her?
Looking in the mirror together with Cinderella sounds fun.
Helping Abe with her bubble research sounds good too.
Oh, that's her.
Let's also play on the seesaw with Hansel and Gretel.
Oh my god.
I can't believe she's making Cinderella do stuff for her.
Oh, cause...
Oh my god.
Because they're all based off of fairy tales.
I just realized.
That's why she's Little Mermaid.
The Heracle Crew is based off of like fairy tales.
Wait, what?
What happened to them?
What did you do?
Oh.
What do the bubbles mean?
Little Mermaid?
What do they mean?
Whoa.
Okay, now I can tell why she's OP.
That's why you don't skip.
I didn't skip!
I always play through every story.
During the events.
Alright, so we're playing this event later on.
What do you mean?
I would never.
Oh, okay.
See, there's the PV that we...
There's the image.
Alright.
That's interesting.
That's...
So that's Little Mermaid that we're definitely gonna get.
Alright, there's...
Now it's off to the storyline preview.
Oh, it's the sound guy.
I hope the sound's been alright so far.
The last piece of paradise on the surface.
Oh, this is a huge chapter.
Whoa!
Turn that down a little.
Who is she?
What is...
Whoa!
Guys, this is chapter 37 and chapter 38.
Who is she?
My new wife.
I don't know, but I wanna know.
Mam, do you need a hand?
Maybe two?
What?
Die, traitors!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
It's time to power up!
Oh my god!
That's me!
Hahaha!
New chapter update.
Well, guys...
On the 30th anniversary, I will find out who she is.
She might revive right away!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
There's more of them?
What?
I recognize that outfit.
It's her.
Oh my god, it's her!
There they are!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, there's more of them!
Oh my...
Okay, that was interesting.
I'll get there on the 30th anniversary.
I...
I'll get there.
Oh, alright.
Last video.
Was that Rappi?
Oh, is that one...
Which one's Rappi?
Oh, the contest to Kee is missing.
I got enough context here.
Alright.
And then, here's the 25th anniversary video.
So, there's the new story event.
There's Little Mermaid.
Oh, the artist is so beautiful, though.
What is this?
Wait, an island...
Oh, is this the world for her event?
Alright, so there's...
So there's...
There's Little Mermaid.
That's the free character you can get.
There's Mori.
And then, there's Mihara with...
Jesus Christ.
There's...
Wait, let me look at what...
Wait, what does Mihara look like now?
Wait, that's Mihara.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
What?
Oh my...
Wait.
Stop.
But that's just me.
What the...
Wait.
That's Mihara?
Wait a minute.
But that's Mihara.
Wait.
Oh my...
Guys, Mihara got...
Got an upgrade.
By the way.
Do you guys remember?
But...
That says Mihara.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, that's Mondernia.
We're...
Sorry.
That's...
That's Mihara.
Sorry.
They both start with M.
Okay.
I was gonna...
Like...
Alright.
That's...
Mihara.
Okay.
What does she look like now?
Sorry.
I need to compare.
Oh!
Alright.
So, if you guys didn't know...
Mihara...
Mihara became an SSR...
Um...
With the anniversary update.
So, this is what she looks like now.
This is what she was before.
So, she got...
She became...
She got an extra S in there.
Um...
Oh, whoa.
Yeah.
She got some major upgrades.
Uh...
Alright.
So, there's...
Oh, my gosh.
She has, like, bubble...
Oh, my God.
Her entire text...
Are bubbles.
Like to be shackled.
Enough business.
You're...
But I...
That's just the freaking beauty that you're gonna get.
I...
Hi.
Oh.
This will go well with my...
Okay.
Thanks.
Oh, and these are the new outfits you're gonna get.
Ooh.
Abyss flower.
Oh, is this, like, one new outfit?
Is there somewhere darker or quieter we can go?
It's too bright here.
A gulp?
I was like, whoa, bubble!
Oh, wow!
Okay, um, those are some cool bubbles from that outfit.
Yeah!
Oh, and then, oh, and then your little, sorry, the little town got updated to celebrate the 2.5 year anniversary!
Look at that!
You can get the 160 free, free recruits!
Oh, calm down, Toki!
Look, I was just talking about the bubbles!
Yes, yes, what color were her eyes, Toki?
I, I don't know, I was looking at the, the very cute bubbles that, um, that the little mermaid had in her, in her beautiful costume!
You know?
Like, it was like, look at that!
Look at that!
Bubbles!
See?
Look at that!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Uh, okay!
Oh, so yeah!
Happy, happy 2 year anniversary!
Hehehehe!
2 point year...
Not 2 year, sorry!
2.5 year anniversary!
Guys!
I'm so excited!
Um...
Uh, well, f- Oh, give me a sec!
Let me hydrate real quick!
We're looking at the bubbles right now!
We're looking at the bubbles right now, guys!
Look, see?
Alright, p- I forgot you're the ear!
Um...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
So, as you see, we're, we're gonna be doing a gacha!
Ha ha!
To only get the little mermaid!
Hehehehe!
Guys!
Of course!
The little mermaid!
Guys!
Do you guys wanna get the little mermaid too?
Cause you can do your polls right now!
If you do exclamation point decay!
Woo hoo hoo hoo hoo!
Don't you wanna- Don't you wanna do it?
Guys!
If you click on my link, um...
If you- If you- Just give me a sec!
If you click my link right now, you get up to...
A hundred and, uh...
A hundred and sixty, uh, um...
Up to 160 polls!
So you too can get the little mermaid!
And, like, you know, and the others, you know?
Ha ha!
Might not be as good as the little mermaid!
But you could also, I guess you could get Mihara!
I...
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
H... I...
I guess you could get her too!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Um...
I keep forgetting to save the sound profile.
Uh... Oh, it's Mahara's... Sorry.
Mahara is later.
So, like, you know, after you get a little mermaid, maybe...
I guess you could save for Mahara later, you know, I guess.
But, like, we're all here for...
We're all here for the little mermaid!
Alright.
Let's go.
Let me know, sound guy, let me know.
Oh, uh... Oh, we have their... I got a free one, too.
Alright, let's do our free... Wait.
No, let's do our free... Wouldn't it be cool if we get our free mermaid right now?
I think we can do it.
I think... Wait, actually, before we do, let's claim our rewards.
I will... I like my free stuff real quick.
Welcome back.
Let me get my free stuff.
Yay!
Free stuff!
Manual confirmed.
I love free stuff.
Alright, and then... What was the day-by-day?
That's free, too, right?
Free!
Free stuff!
Alright.
Okay, now that I've done my...
Wait.
Did I do all my free stuff?
Did I do all of it?
Free stuff!
Let's go!
Free!
Alright.
Wait, do I have more?
Oh, my God.
I have more free stuff.
Nice.
I know... Okay, let me just claim all.
I'm...
I've decided to do a claim all.
Yippee!
I don't know.
I just like the adrenaline of claiming the free stuff one by one.
And then I realized, oh, wait.
I have too many free things.
Anyway.
Let's do that.
Let's...
You know what?
I think it's possible.
Let's do one on...
Oh, wait.
That's not...
That's just a thing.
Alright.
It's fine.
We...
It had to happen.
Alright.
Having the one plan had to happen.
Okay?
Like...
It's just...
Oh, hey!
It's Raffy!
Alright.
Nope.
Get me out of here.
Alright.
Now...
We're gonna get the Little Mermaid right here.
Okay.
Before I do the poll, Sound Guy!
Is everything okay, Sound Guy?
Or Chat?
Chat!
Is everything sounding great so far?
Um...
Good ol' regular Raffy.
Everything's okay?
Alright.
Yes, it's good.
Let's...
Let's pull...
The Little Mermaid.
Okay.
I got nothing.
That's fine.
You know?
That's...
That's okay.
I'm...
Sometimes you...
You gotta get through the dust to get...
Wait, what's she?
Do I have her?
Wait, I don't have her.
She's new, right?
Nice to meet you.
Okay, and then I don't care about them.
Soldier F.A.
Okay, that...
She's new.
Okay, I got like a million Tetris.
Soldier F .A.
It's fine.
Don't you know?
There's a fine line between pleasure and pain.
I'm Nia.
Nice to meet you.
Alright, let's do that again.
Alright, let's...
Alright, let's do it again.
I'm okay.
We're here for the Little Mermaid.
Woo!
I'm good.
I'm good, guys.
Wait, is that her?
Get out.
Please.
Okay, wait.
Did I get her?
No!
Who the fuck are you?
Who even are you?
You're not in my anniversary event.
But...
But she's...
Dude, she was not...
She's not in the PV.
She does not matter.
Nice to meet you.
I have enough SSR.
I need the busted meta characters.
Yes, but...
But is she meta, guys?
That's the most important part.
Is she meta?
There's a fine line between pleasure...
She's...
Please.
Get out.
I'm trying to resist temptation.
I'm trying to resist.
I'm...
Not one bit.
All right.
She's hot.
She's meta in my heart.
Come on.
That's gold eyes.
Wait, that's two.
Okay.
Okay, this is it.
This is it.
We got two golds.
The odds are...
We got double.
We got doubles.
The odds are in our favor.
Okay.
Okay, get out.
I don't care about you, Tetra, and Ellison.
Who's here?
TLC for the sick.
Painful shots for the malingerers.
Oh my god.
Easter's over.
Get out.
It's the little mermaid's time to shine.
All right, it's fine.
I still have no chance.
Come on.
Is that her?
Is that you?
It is so adorable.
I'll get rid of anything standing in your way.
Anything.
Whoa, she'll do anything.
Oh, is she the worst pilgrim?
Oh.
That's why she'll do anything.
The worst?
What?
Oh, Jesus.
Oh my god.
She sounds incredibly...
Okay, guys, look.
Of all the pilgrims you can get, she is the worst.
Guys, stop.
My luck is not that bad.
Guys, it's gonna turn around right now.
This is it.
I get all the bad things now.
So now, I'll get the little mermaid.
How do you lose the 50?
Guys, it's okay.
This...
Okay.
I get all the bad stuff now.
So now, I should get the good stuff.
Right here.
That's fine.
I might have got a million fucking purple hair, girl.
But it's okay.
This is it.
How would I lose my 50-50?
How?
Right here.
Right now.
My luck changes.
Where are the gold eyes?
Are you serious?
Are you...
Get it.
Stop stalking me.
Please.
Please, let me have my life.
Get out of my head.
Get...
How much do I have?
Okay, there's still...
I have two more pulls.
I have...
It's fine.
This is it.
This time.
Get out of my head.
Hurry up.
Gold eyes.
Come on.
Give me the gold eyes.
Are you...
Oh my god!
Okay, it's okay.
I still have other... I still have the one pause, guys.
That's fine.
We still last... Okay, this is... This is fine.
This is fine.
This is it.
This is... We... We... Blunked the other pause.
And... So that... So that... It's all part of, like, the streaming plan, you know?
Like, we build up the tension.
We build up the tension and then, like...
This time... We build up the tension.
And on the final pull... That's when, like... And then you get... And then we get it.
And then it becomes a clippable moment.
And...
This is part of my streamer plan.
This is it.
Right here.
And then it's gonna give me golden eyes.
Right?
The eyes are gonna be gold.
Right, guys?
The... The eyes... Yellow eyes!
Wait... Oh... Oh!
It's okay.
It's part of the streamer plan.
Where... Um... I'm gonna get it on the single pulls.
That's where it's gonna happen.
So, like, I build up so much tension and hype.
That, like, I have at least five single pulls.
Where I'm gonna get it.
I...
Right here.
Right now.
Also, Namas, thank you for gifting a sub to desperate play.
No, no, no.
This is where all the real tension boils up to.
We're gonna get the single pulls.
And then... And then she's gonna show up there.
There.
That's where the... That's where all the real hype is.
And then... And then it's gonna become a clippable moment.
Wait.
Did it... Did it, like, go extras?
Oh, no.
It's just a regular.
It's okay.
We still have the single pulls.
Right here.
Oh, wait.
It's... It turned blue.
Is that good?
Is blue a good color?
It's okay.
We still have more.
It's gonna be the very last one.
Oh, my God.
Please.
No.
Oh, they can't do this to me.
They can't... Oh, my God.
Thank you.
Can you...
Do I have enough free stuff?
Let me... Give me a sec.
Guys, what gives me free pulls?
Guys.
Do I have anything in here that can... None of... Do I...
The credit card?
I don't understand.
What happened to me?
What... What happened?
I used to be the luckiest bird of all time when I came to...
I couldn't get any character I've ever wanted.
What happened?
What happened to me?
I... I don't understand.
I... I don't...
I don't... What happened?
I...
Oh, my luck.
It's okay.
I have...
I have you.
I...
I don't really want to get...
I have you.
I like to have my commander.
It's okay.
Oh.
It feels good.
It's so...
I don't...
It's okay.
I have another one.
Well, I can enjoy the battle a bit more.
Now, you're big and strong.
It's alright.
Get out of here, crow.
I'm always ready.
Alright.
It's okay.
I have her.
That's...
Do I?
There's pity?
Do I have enough pity, guys?
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I have one more.
I have...
Guys.
I have one more.
It's not...
Guys.
It's not over.
I have one more, Paul.
It's not...
We have one more.
This is it.
Right here.
It was a blue.
It was...
This is the one last chance.
It was a blue.
Manny, thank you for the thousand pitties.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay, guys, guys.
No, no, no, no.
Guys, guys, wait.
Wait, there's still... It's okay.
That piece I can level up for more.
I like to have...
It's okay, guys.
At least I got to level her up a little more.
Wait, go ahead to event to claim two more?
Oh my god, it's not over.
Wait, what do I do?
Is this?
No, that just gives me that.
How do I...
How do I claim another?
Go to the event tab.
Okay, I did it.
What do I do?
Look, this one?
Oh!
Oh my god, free gotcha.
Oh my, it's not... Guys, it's not over.
Guys, it's not over, guys.
There's still hope, but it's not over.
Come and make a fortune.
Oh, it's okay.
It's free anyway.
Okay, that wasn't it.
Alright.
Okay, is this the event?
Okay, we'll do that.
Oh, wait.
Wait, there's so much more.
Wait a minute.
There's so much more.
There's the anniversary pass.
Oh my god, claim off.
Okay, none of those work.
Wait, did I do everything?
Mission.
Claim off.
Okay, I don't know what I got.
Alright.
What did I get?
Vault claim.
Confirmed.
That's not enough.
That's only two.
Okay.
That's five.
I get a free Mori, too.
Alright, that's cool.
Maybe if you need me to do anything.
I guess.
That's cool.
I don't care about you.
You can get her for free, by the way.
That's how you get her for free.
Thank you for the...
Oh my god.
She gave me free temples.
Never mind.
Oh my god.
Remember what I said about you?
It's okay.
I didn't mean that.
You gave me the one thing I wanted.
Alright, it's time.
This is it.
Right here.
Right now.
This is it.
Oh my god.
I love Mori now.
Oh my
god.
I love Mori now.
I got...
There must be more than I can claim.
Surely.
Okay.
I'm level two.
Is there any more that I can claim?
Surely there's more, right?
Surely.
No, no.
I'm not done.
It's not over yet.
There's surely more.
Okay.
Confirmed.
Alright.
What else?
Okay.
I get hearts.
Alright.
Four points.
Is there anything else?
Is there anything else I can claim?
Surely there's one more thing I can claim.
Right?
Is there...
Surely there's more.
What?
Is there nothing more?
Is there nothing more I can claim?
Oh my god.
The CD keys.
How do I do that?
How do I do the CD keys, guys?
No, no, no.
Where?
It's not over!
There's still...
Oh!
Resupply quest.
Okay.
It's never over until...
Until I say it's over.
Okay.
Wait.
Do I use it?
Do I do it?
Oh no.
Okay.
I didn't do it.
There's no more.
I clicked all the red dots.
But this is the story.
We don't play story yet.
Guys.
Initiating operation...
No!
Why did you do...
Alright.
I guess we play a little bit.
We go through the story a little bit.
The objective is to eradicate all of the E2 crystals in the crystal region.
And complete the groundwork for the future expansion of reclamation site 01.
We'll get there eventually, little bro.
In form.
Thank you for the 1550s.
Thank you.
In form.
Thank you for gifting us subs to coping.
It's not over, guys.
It's not over.
There are no squads that have been officially deployed to the crystal region.
Of course, we can't discount the fact that there might be squads who came out of...
I don't understand.
I was the luckiest bird.
And gotcha.
I would get characters within two or three pulls.
What happened to me?
No need case should be caught up in any trouble.
You guys...
You took all my luck.
You took...
You absorbed all my luck!
Confirming landing coordinates.
Firing AA pillar towards...
You!
Launch complete.
Transferring control to the operator until landing.
Sorry, Toki.
I got her hit 20 pulls.
That's right!
All set.
Landing now.
Thanks for the luck, Toki.
Landing in...
Three minutes?
Descends much slower than the A pillar.
Maybe because it's so much larger.
The energy contained within it is significantly greater than that of the A pillar.
Well...
But this appears to be an urgent call.
It's okay.
You guys want up to 160 pulls and absorb more of my luck!
You captured a rare specimen?
Exclamation point, Nikke.
Where are you right now?
I'm sorry.
Get away from there immediately.
I have nothing more to lose.
Huh?
Mana?
I'm picking up a strange signal near the AA pillar.
What?
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Colossal entity of some kind burst...
What?
Why does it have...
Teeth?
It has like double sets of teeth like fish.
Whoa!
Ugh!
That sound effect was disgusting.
What the mouth do?
That's...
Higher AA pillar!
Wait, it swallowed the entire pillar?
This is emergency!
How hungry!
Ha ha ha ha!
Tell them...
Code name...
Gluttony has appeared!
Wait, that's gluttony?
That's a sin!
I hear the sound of something falling in the water.
And my body begins to sink underneath the surface.
I think I'm drowning.
Who's that?
Is that mermaid?
How long can Anike breathe underwater again?
How long can my body last?
It's not over, Xerantor.
It's not over.
Who will come to save me?
There's still time!
I could get more pulls!
If I noticed without you...
I wouldn't have accepted that offer.
It's not over until the stream ends!
I didn't want to die.
I don't...
I don't wanna die.
Die!
Someone...
You won't die!
Oh, that's mermaid!
Someone grabs my hand...
You won't die!
Yeah!
Oh, there's Mori!
There's my free character!
Wait, she's breathing underwater!
Wait...
Well, there's an underground...
Underwater tree!
Am I really dead?
Oh, there she is!
Bitch!
There's that bitch!
Is that a fairy?
Hmm- Ha ha ha!
Oh!
U- Whoa!
Tokey!
Hah ha ha ha ha!
Unbreakable spear...
Hah ha ha ha!
You will never get her now!
I swear, I'll get her!
I'll fucking get her!
Give me, give me the voucher!
Healing away!
give me...
Give me the voucher!
Alright, let's see.
What's the challenge?
Okay, go to... Is there anything here?
What's this?
Oh, challenge mode.
Oh, it gives me like another voucher.
Alright, get out.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
No, don't say that.
Don't say that.
I don't... It won't happen.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
This is it.
We got this.
Okay, not this one.
We got the next one.
Okay, that's not it.
Wait, someone said you could get free gems in the shop.
Oh my god, really?
That's a thing?
Alright, let's see.
Shop.
I will do everything you need.
Okay, um... That's zero dollars.
Where's the free stuff?
I thought... Oh, it's in the cash shop?
Okay, cash shop.
Where's my free stuff?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, there's free stuff.
There it is.
Okay.
Okay, we got one of our free stuff.
Is there any more free stuff?
Is there... Oh, this isn't free.
Oh, there's more.
There's 10.
10.
And then there's 50.
And then there's 100.
Okay, we have another free pull, guys.
We have... That's fine.
Guys, we have another...
Oh my god.
And we got another 50 here.
Okay, this is... This is possible.
Alright.
Alright, now...
Now, we have... We got one more pull.
I'm like... I'm like looking through the couches for loose change.
This is it.
Right here.
Right now.
This is it.
Right here.
Oh my god.
I fucking...
Why is it purple?
Okay.
Alright.
We have more loose change, guys.
Alright, here we go.
Where... What... What do we click for it?
Which one's the...
Okay.
Now we have CD keys.
This is fine.
Wait, there's more stuff.
Wait, that's not it.
What do we do?
Let's scroll down the CD key.
Okay, here we go.
Alright.
What's the CD key, guys?
Guys, what is it?
Let me hide this real quick.
Guys, what's the CD key?
Okay.
Codes...
Codes to enter.
This is it.
Right here.
Alright.
Redeemed.
I don't know what I got.
But I'm using all these CD keys.
Something will happen.
I believe.
You guys just don't...
You guys just need to start believing more, chat.
It's cause...
None of you...
You guys all stopped believing.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, I got all of it.
Alright.
Okay, how much did I get?
Wait, how much did I get from that?
Did I get it?
Oh my god.
I'm rich.
Guys, look.
Guys, look, I'm rich.
Oh my god.
That's enough for two more pulls.
I'm so rich.
That's enough.
That's two more pulls.
Right here.
Oh my god.
Please.
Come on.
How did I...
That's enough for one more.
I have one more.
This is it.
Right here.
Oh.
Nice to meet you.
Okay, but what if...
I just...
I purchased 3,000 gems.
Wait, I have clothes?
What do you mean clothes?
How do I use my clothes?
I can pity her?
Oh my god.
Is it possible?
Wait, what's this?
Wait, do I have pity?
I...
No.
I did it.
I will never fall.
Never falter.
For I must keep the promise I made to everyone.
I did it.
Yippee!
You're so...
What is she?
You're so beautiful.
If Abe could see me now, I'm sure she...
What should I...
I should keep talking.
Or else I...
might forget how to speak.
Alright!
I did it.
I can't speak normally.
You're beautiful.
I shall make you wear clothes.
To cover you up.
What?
Alright.
At best, you might as well be strong for me.
Why?
Let them free.
You might as well be big and strong for me.
I did it.
Yippee!
Wait, what's her new costume?
Wait, is this the...
Oh my god!
She's just in a bubble?
Wait, how does she attack...
Oh wait, no.
It just...
Okay.
Oh my god!
Wait, she just shoved bubble out of her hands!
Her ammo is her hands!
That's cool.
Okay, wait, what does she look like here?
Okay.
Oh my god, her bubbles!
She has like bubble hands.
What is this like...
Oh, I was gonna say, does she actually walk?
Hahaha!
Does she...
Does she actually know how to walk?
Or does she just...
Or does she just like use...
Use the bubbles?
Alright.
I'm...
I'm so happy for me.
I'm so...
Happy.
Guys, look!
I pulled her!
Guys, I told you!
Guys, I told you I can pull me hard!
Not me, sorry.
Sorry, she's still in my mind.
I told you we can pull the little mermaid, guys!
You just gotta believe!
Look at that!
I told you!
Or else I might forget how to speak!
See, guys!
We did it!
We...
And I did it without using my credit card for more money!
Alright!
We did it!
Yay!
I'm so happy...
I'm so happy for me!
I...
Oh my god!
Get out of here!
Where's me?
Where is she?
I need her on here!
Guys, how do I change the characters in this area?
I keep forgetting how to do it!
How do I change the characters?
Top right?
We're in top right!
Top right corner?
Top right?
And then what do I do?
Lobby?
Alright!
Get out of here!
I don't need you!
Wait, how do I turn you off?
Here?
Oh wait!
It's like this!
Okay!
And then...
Her!
And...
Who else do I want in here?
I want...
Can I have two...
Wait, can I have two...
Oh, I could have...
Um...
Where's the other one?
Where is she?
There we go!
I'll move it here!
Alright, nice!
Alright!
Oh, when she goes to...
Ah, point!
Oh, she forgot to speak!
It's been so long!
To me!
Alright, guys!
So...
Guys!
By the way, it's not just gacha, guys!
We also...
I guess...
Look at that!
I told you!
You guys were like...
She'll never get...
Get...
She'll never get the little mermaid!
I proved you wrong!
I told you I can get her!
Any means possible!
Alright, let's do the story!
So...
Apparently, she's been stuck in gluttony stomach for a while now!
And...
We can try a little bit of the story before we do bubbles!
Hey, guys!
If you guys want to try your hand!
I'm trying to get the little mermaid and do it first try like I did!
Uh...
You know...
You can also...
You can sign up right now!
Um...
And click the link below!
Or click the link in chat!
Use exclamation point Nikke!
Or click the link that...
That's pinned in chat!
And sign up!
And get...
Up to 160 free pulls!
And you too!
Can get the little mermaid in one pull!
Just like me!
How many chapters do I have to do to do the minigame chat?
Axis denied?
Alright!
How do we want to do this?
Okay!
Her!
Cinderella!
Mori!
Wait!
I have to upgrade Mori too!
And then Mihara!
I'm always ready!
And...
Then we need like one fire I guess!
Wait!
We don't have...
Aw man!
Chapter 5?
Wait!
In the...
In the story?
Guys, I know I could use trial characters.
But I was trying to get to chapter 5.
And like...
I actually used up all their turns.
Because I forgot I was using trial characters.
I...
I forgot...
I forgot I was using trial characters.
I...
Alright.
This is good, right?
This is a good lineup.
Oh!
For events are infinite!
Get out of here, Modernia!
She's level 200.
Oh!
Nice!
That's what I've always wanted.
Alright!
I think...
We can get rid of her then.
And grab...
What's her?
And grab her.
Are you planning on attending class, Commander?
Wait!
Leader!
I heard she was good.
Alright!
We're ready.
Nice!
Guys!
Do you think we're gonna win this?
Do you...
Do you think we're gonna win this event, guys?
I think...
Wait!
Do I have burst two?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
One...
Is that a two?
No, that's a three.
Okay, we have...
Okay.
Fuck!
I guess we do need a more...
Wait!
Actually, she's two.
Alright.
One, two, three.
We have so many threes.
But, like, we have to have Mihara there.
Like, we can't replace her, guys.
Right?
She...
She has to be there.
It's mandatory.
I'm not a fairy?
It says there that, like, there's a bonus that we put her in, guys.
It's all about the bonus.
A simple-minded.
Thank you for the hundred pitties.
Thank you.
Wait.
Where am I?
Very...
So cute.
See?
I told you!
She had to be there!
Who are you?
What is this place?
Where did you bring me?
We're all Nikkeis, aren't we?
Are you a Nikkei, too?
A Nikkei?
Yeah.
And we're at the bottom of the ocean right now.
You just said you knew you were a Nikkei before.
Is that amazing?
We're underwater?
We're breathing underwater.
Don't be ridiculous.
Do you really think I'd fall for that?
I know it's hard to believe.
I was thinking the same thing only a few minutes ago.
What?
Are you ever pulled down here, too?
Yuni and I woke up just a little while ago, too.
Who's Yuni?
It seems like we were in a shipwreck, like you.
Isn't that right, Yuni?
Wait, is she a playable character, too?
What is going on?
What are your names, by the way?
I have to be able to call you something.
You weren't traveling together?
Nope.
This is my first time seeing her.
Oh, normal Yuni is.
Oh, okay.
And this is my partner, Yuni, who is dear to me.
Cool.
As you can see, Yuni is a little different than the usual Nikkei.
She does not need to wrap this around herself.
She communicates with these vocalizations that I personally find adorable.
She still understands everything we're saying, though.
So you'll still be able to communicate with her.
No, no, she does.
You don't understand.
It's part of her programming.
It's more accurate, necessarily.
If she doesn't, she'll die.
She does contain all sorts of wonders.
You don't want her to die, do you, Doki?
Siren.
That's a pretty name.
And you, kiddo?
Who are you calling kiddo?
Yeah.
She's just the same age as you.
Just with...
Just a little smaller.
Good.
You know, just like one size smaller.
Any chance you can fill us in on where we are?
I saw you falling into the ocean near the bubble tree.
I saved you.
And waited until you came too.
Wow.
So you saved us.
Thanks a bunch.
So...
Are we really underwater right now?
Yeah, why aren't your clothes wet?
If they're underwater.
How can we be underwater?
We're all able to breathe perfectly normal.
Yeah.
Is that transparent barrier protecting us?
Oh!
Barrier?
That's how...
Wait, does a little mermaid not have to breathe water?
It's actually true.
So this place really is at the bottom of the ocean?
I never knew a place like this existed.
Who's watering this tree, then?
Could it be a new lost sector?
It's Atlantis!
Siowyn would certainly be happy to hear that.
How do we get back up?
SpongeBob type shit.
Wet t-shirts.
Now!
My immersion!
Where is my immersion?
They were in water a moment ago.
Excuse me?
You mean there isn't a way to get back up now?
In other words, we're trapped down here?
Hmm...
No.
This can't be happening.
I need to go.
If I don't get out of here, I'll lose the opportunity I worked so hard for.
Wait, what's she working for?
This is all one big lie.
I don't believe we're underwater for a second.
What do you mean?
That's all...
Nanobots.
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
It's all fake.
I'm not waiting around.
Get out of my way.
I've got to get out of here right now.
Yeah, let her swim out.
Then...
Then we'll get what we want.
Oh?
How about we all settle down for a moment and get some food in us first?
Oh, okay.
By getting food, do you mean fight?
Oh, do we have to like...
Are we fighting the...
We're fighting for our food!
Oh!
Man, I sure do love...
Okay, guys.
See, look.
I'll play the game.
Wait, where is she?
Give me just a second.
There we go.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Wait.
Oh my god!
It's so fast, too.
The shots.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Okay, nice.
We'll just shoot that.
Nice.
Alright.
Yeah, it feels like it's SMG when I use her.
It lacked a certain pizzazz, but I'm satisfied.
I like how like her SSR version, she like hit like second puberty.
Like her voice gets deeper.
Alright.
It's okay.
We hunted some robots and now we have food.
What are you looking at?
Is it tasty?
If it wasn't, do you think I'd be eating it?
Now stop staring at me as I eat.
It's good to see you eating so enthusiastically.
Yeah, like her voice got so deep.
Their SSR version.
Upgrades in many ways.
Whoa!
Stop calling me cute!
Oh!
B-baka!
Oh no, she's a tsundere.
Aw,
she's socially awkward.
Wait, what?
Just swim up!
That's right.
Still, I will send you all back.
Yeah, I was gonna say, just swim up.
By trying doing the opposite of how I rescued you, it might be possible.
And how did you rescue us?
Aha!
How did she do it?
Just fly.
Forms at her fingertips.
Yeah, it's a bubble!
Huh?
What is that?
It's a bubble!
It's called a bubble!
I was able to save you by putting you in one of these!
It's a bubble.
Have you not seen a bubble before?
Are you sure you're not a quarry after all?
No way!
Oh my god!
A bubble!
I'm just kidding around.
So, that's what you use to save us, huh?
Oh!
I have the power of the kotodama!
The kotodama?
The power which I can also imbue the bubbles with!
Oh!
It means I don't have to physically move them myself!
I like how her clothes are, like, based off of, like, fish skills.
Kotodama?
Huh?
What's that?
Are you using this kotodama thing now?
Oh no!
Certainly not!
In the post-apocalyptic world, people don't- Normally don't see bubbles?
Like, do they not use soap?
Have they never, like, accidentally, like, seen bubbles on soap?
Like...
Do they not need a shower?
Slash, bathe?
I don't realize what a joyful experience speaking with someone could be!
Oh!
She's an extrovert!
Into a way to form bubbles inside my throat!
As a way to be able to control the kotodama!
Check your pre-apocalypse take privilege!
And how I won't use the kotodama against either of you accidentally!
Haha!
Good to know!
Why don't you use that power now and send us back up?
I'm sorry!
I used too many bubbles when I rescued you!
Aren't they, like...
They're, like, androids, though.
They're, like, partially human.
So when they're, like, human self need, like, you know...
You know, like, you still need to clean your robots, too.
Like, you have to, like...
I can't wait that long.
I need to...
Sorry, and cyborg.
I keep, like, getting mixed up.
Maybe I can swim out of here somehow.
If you leave this bubble, you will die!
I forgot human...
Humanoid robots.
I would get mixed up between cyborgs and androids.
Androids is, like, they look like humans, but they're not actually humans.
And cyborg is, like, partially human.
How am I supposed to trust a stranger I just met?
I thought some of them were, like...
Part...
Like, cyborgs, though.
Yeah, the brain is lit.
Oh!
I'm going to...
Mori.
It would be best not to leave.
Are you really taking her at her word?
I am.
She seems quite certain of what she's saying.
There must be a reason for that.
What?
Oh, so they're full of...
So, like, whatever scientists design...
Mihara!
I just assumed, because I thought they were cyborgs, that Mihara requested this.
Because that's, like, her past self.
But...
Now I understand.
I promise.
Ah...
So please...
Be patient and wait for a little while.
Hmm...
A little while.
I'm going to be waiting for an entire month.
Fine.
But not a moment longer.
Oh!
And bodies that match with what they felt comfortable with as humans, else they go haywire.
Why?
Okay, I don't want to know why Mihara wanted upgrades.
I...
They're like, I don't feel comfortable with this body anymore.
I need more.
Is there anything we can do to help while you make the bubble for our escape?
It was necessary, Doki.
Or she'll die!
Guys, if you guys want to find out why Mihara needed upgrades, make sure to click the link pinned in chat or use exclamation point Nikkei to find out yourself.
If you guys want to take this out, give us something back.
Please, let us help.
We can do anything.
Guys, she needed this.
Or she'll fucking die!
In that case...
Alright, nice.
Do we need to get to...
How far do we have to get to to unlock the minigame?
Like five?
One five?
Like, is it one five?
Or is it, like, all the way to...
He... at the end?
Just get to one five?
Okay.
Just one five.
Alright.
Okay, I want to use...
I want to use...
The person I got in one try.
Okay, we just need a big boss to come in.
Jesus, her...
Her gun is so fast.
The SMG?
It does feel like an SMG because it actually happens so fast.
Like...
Like, they barely survive.
Also, to be fair...
Um...
I am, like...
50,000 above the power level.
What a truly beautiful story this was.
I am most pleased with it.
Alright.
One three.
Yeah, I am 50.
Guys, do you think I win?
I'm not sure yet.
But...
I think I might win this.
I almost skipped the story.
All this stuff.
The story remains of plants, buildings, submarines, and more life scattered around.
Oh my god, she is like a little mermaid.
I'm certain that I've seen it before.
Look at this stuff.
Isn't it neat?
An AA pillar?
Oh!
So that's what it's called.
Oh my god, we're in Gluttony!
The point of our energy still stored inside it.
But it seems to have stopped working.
That's why we can't leave.
It's like the Gluttony swallowed the A pillar.
There sure are a lot of fascinating things in this place.
So it is war!
We're in the stomach!
Let me guess.
You want us to start rummaging through this stuff.
Look around and bring back anything that appears useful.
Yeah, cause earlier they're like, He swallowed an AA pillar.
Always comes back to war.
It's okay, just get out your credit card.
You don't have to scavenge anything.
Just get out your...
Just get out the commander's credit card.
We'll buy our way out of here.
Sifting through wreckage for valuable items sounds fun to me.
Namaste gifter, thank you for gifting a sub to Vore.
Pay the lead!
Let's go!
Good luck making those bubbles, Siren.
Make my bubbles now.
What the heck are those?
Oh, it's the bubbles!
Right.
Those are all made up of bubbles.
Didn't you say they were robots of some kind?
Bounce, bounce!
Oh my god, the bubbles have their own voice actors.
Hmph.
I've never seen robots that playful.
Welcome, Vore.
No, wait!
Vore is real?!
Go away!
Oh my god!
He's real!
I'm sorry.
I'm like looking at...
Oh my god!
And he has Minecraft 15th anniversary!
Cute!
No way!
Surely it wouldn't hurt to touch it.
Just once.
I thought it was just a concept!
Yeah!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Gah!
What?
What is it?
I thought you'd be lonely over here by yourself.
Well, think again.
I'm not lonely at all.
I see.
You're very impressive.
Don't treat me like a little kid.
All right, all right.
So cute.
Why did you really come over here?
Yeah.
Are you trying to pilfer everything that I gathered?
Huh?
We're all here to work together!
Or do you want me to head over to your side and help you find more stuff?
Hmm.
Why is she so like...
If that's the case, then get lost.
Why does she trust anybody?
I'll do no such thing.
I'm not after any of that.
Doki, you need to play up to chapter 30 to find out.
Why would I do any of that stuff?
I can read your minds.
I know that is exactly what you guys are gonna say.
Okay.
It's just a small task that Siren gave us.
Oh.
Right.
I guess this isn't an official mission or anything.
Hmm.
Where are their commanders?
Wait, that's me!
Everyone...
Everyone's like, oh my god, what happened to her?
We are going to be spending a lot of time together.
But I don't know anything about you.
And it's going to stay that way.
As soon as I leave this place, I won't see you ever again.
Yeah.
Wait, but I thought they were all like...
If they're all Nikes, then wouldn't they all like, eventually like, bump into each other?
Because they're all like...
I assume they all come from the same factory, right?
Sorry.
I didn't mean to disturb you.
We'll leave you be.
See you later.
No?
They don't...
Not really?
They don't come from the same factory?
Where are you looking at?
I thought like, Nikkei was like a trademark.
Like, you know, like...
Um...
Like, from...
Honda Civic?
You know?
Like, I thought it was a factory name.
I didn't realize it was like...
Just like, you know, they're just called robots, but they're called Nikkeis instead.
So...
You know?
They all come from the same...
They all come from the same factory.
She has no idea.
Oh, it's like a...
It's like a phone.
She doesn't know who I tracked.
Or what kind of mission I was given.
Oh, so there's three main manufacturers.
You just need to do one thing.
Wait, can there be bootleg Nikkeis then?
Whoa.
Just tell me what they choose.
That is uncomfortable for her boob.
Like...
Are there bootleg Nikkeis?
One month left.
Yeah.
Simple.
Maybe for you all.
Bunch of liars.
Kinda, but no?
Why hasn't anyone made like...
Counterfeit Nikkeis?
They can be...
They can be cheaper and...
Wouldn't that be better?
More affordable?
Even you can...
Even you can own a Nikkei.
Ask the government.
Get your...
Get your Nikkei robot on the street for $5.
Lot, you know?
Like those tables.
Where you can like...
I am most pleased with it.
Bootleg DVDs and stuff.
Imagine if they're like in...
In like off-brand like designer bags.
Imagine you just grab and...
Buy like a cheaper Nikkei there.
Might not be as good, but...
What are you making that face for?
You gathered so much!
We did!
Yeah, we killed a lot of robots for this.
Wow!
That's not that much, is it?
Are you happy?
Yeah!
I didn't know so many things were hiding in there.
Did you never search that place?
Uh-huh.
I mean, she could barely talk.
I never needed much when I was alone.
Yeah, she just existed.
Wait, does she like, have to eat?
Do Nikkei's have to eat?
But they're robots.
I guess you gotta give them oil, right?
Or I guess charge their batteries?
They have to eat and drink?
What's the point of being a robot if you have to eat?
That's so pain.
That's like...
That's like some fucked up shit the factory did.
They're just like...
It's to pretend to be alive.
What kind of person programmed that into them?
Are you sure it's okay to use a bubble cycle?
Just delete it out of their mind.
What if it delays our escape?
Oh, is it stopped?
Oh, I know about the switching.
I remember that.
Oh, I see.
It's like a psychological thing.
Yeah, but if they can manipulate their mind, just delete the concept of drinking and eating from their mind.
And just like reprogram, be like, humans do not need to eat or drink.
And then write that as a code file.
You know?
Just manipulate the mind.
That's inhumane.
They're wasting food in apocalyptic society.
We have to save food.
Good night, Siren.
See you tomorrow.
I want to go, too.
You're going to go outside?
Yeah.
Let's go outside.
Siren made these beds for us.
She needs some fresh air.
All I'm saying is like, if they're robots, we can act, given literally soiled acid, the Nikkeis are mistreated enough.
I'm saying, we can program, we can delete in the code, we can just write a quick code and be like, Nikkeis don't need to, as a human, you don't need to eat or drink.
Why not?
Because she started following us while we were inside the ark.
It's just simple coding.
I figured that was why you felt that way.
Don't be too harsh on her.
I'm sure she has her reasons for doing it.
I mean, she is, like, going through a lot right now.
If you're not fond of her, I guess there's not what you can do about that.
That food and eating was false.
Exactly!
It's so simple!
I love that.
That's a great code.
We already wrote the code for her.
You do.
Is it because she talks like you do?
And because she rescued us?
You're right.
She rescued us.
And now she's doing her best to help us.
I don't think she's a bad person.
Even though I don't think everything she's telling us is the truth.
Cuckoo!
Why do I think that?
Oh my gosh, she can read clues.
Remember that big mouth thing we saw before we lost consciousness?
Oh, they got bored.
That's where they got bored.
If I was a...
Nikkei researcher...
I'd add that code into their minds.
I'm exhausted.
What is up with this dirt?
I thought it would be soft, but it's practically hard as rock.
Stop.
Is there gold mixed into this stuff or what?
Oh?
Finally, I feel at ease.
Everything has been so...
Uncomfortable.
Was the bed that uncomfortable?
Aw.
Aw, you made her sad.
She made a bed for you.
Oh, you made the bubble sad.
It sounded like digging.
Is that not allowed?
No, it's fine.
Good.
Then don't worry about it.
And move along.
I'm comfortable here.
Yeah, she wants to sleep in dirt.
You don't understand her.
Huh?
What?
Why aren't you leaving?
Mori?
What?
Does it bother you that I dug up the ground?
Do you like cute things?
Aw.
Excuse me?
Oh.
Do you want to see me make bubbles?
That's all she can do.
And she's like, that does not work.
Try second option.
Make bubbles.
He's like, I don't understand.
Why don't you like bubbles?
It's not like I have anything better to do.
Nice.
She did it.
Yay!
Nice.
Two more chapters.
All I'm saying...
I will not back down from this.
I know you guys...
You guys are like, oh my God.
Doki does not care.
All I'm saying...
If I put that in there...
In the coding...
Like, because their brains are programmed, right?
Like, their brains are still from previous humans.
But they just copy the consciousness into the robot.
So I can add a code in there.
And this fixes everything.
Sorry, I forgot.
There's one more code that we need to add.
We need...
Drink.
Need.
False.
There you go.
That's all we need to add.
And then we fix the world.
We...
Okay.
And then...
They'll go insane.
Okay.
Here.
This is what I'll do.
If they'll go insane.
Sane.
There.
That's how I'll fix them.
There we go.
I fixed them.
That's how I'll do it.
It's just that easy.
That would make them more insane.
I got it, guys.
Programming 101.
It's time I teach all of you a lesson.
Alright.
Let's go.
I can't...
What do you mean?
I'm just coding!
Alright.
Let me get rid of these and find more food, I guess.
It's the final boss of Nikkei.
What am I doing wrong?
I don't understand.
I'm just trying to code.
The story will be rewritten into a tale that's happy and beautiful.
Yeah.
Alright.
And then we'll have Bubble March.
Whoa!
Is there a home?
It's her workshop.
Welcome to the Bubble Workshop!
I can't believe this is what was underneath that tree.
Bounce, bounce!
Oh, she made a home in the trees.
What is this place?
It's packed with all sorts of cute things.
Do you like it?
Who said I liked it?
Baka!
She's so soon today.
At the very least, it's not boring.
Oh yeah, look at this stuff.
I'm glad I feel that way!
So, what do I need to do now?
Hello?
Don't you want something from me?
Then why did you bring me here?
Being on your own can be a lonely thing.
Yeah, you don't want to be alone, right?
I never said I was lonely or scared.
Don't go drawing any conclusions.
Bro, you have a lot of issues, Mori.
Well, I'm glad to be proven wrong.
I came to that conclusion because...
That's how I used to be.
You were?
Uh-huh.
But...
She doesn't know what love is.
I can't imagine you ever feeling lonely.
Everyone is at their weakest...
I can't imagine you ever being lonely.
She's been trapped in here alone for seven years.
What the fuck do you mean?
I felt lonely.
She really has never talked to anybody before.
People can get lonely?
Stop you.
Sorry.
She should have the dollar sign lonely...
Dollar sign lonely underscore need equals false.
There we go.
We fixed her.
What is this?
Why are you giving me this?
What did she do?
Hugging onto this...
Will help you sleep better.
Oh, it's like a little cuddle buddy.
What's your deal?
Oh...
Why are you so meaner?
Yeah, this is B.
Why are you being mean to someone nice to you?
Why are you going to such great lengths to save us?
Stop.
She doesn't understand what you're talking about.
She literally learned how to talk.
Speak easier words.
Why are you acting like you don't expect anything from us in return?
I just wanted to rescue you.
So I did.
And I simply wanted to be nice.
Stop confusing your...
Mori.
Whoa!
Makes me uncomfortable.
Don't act all high and mighty.
Whoa!
If you want something, just say it.
And I'll do whatever you tell me to.
Okay, Mori.
I'm sorry.
But I really don't have any ulterior motives.
She's from the streets.
People like you are the worst.
What?
God damn nice people.
Fucking hate them.
Oh, she has baggage.
Oh, dang.
She has a lot of baggage.
It's okay.
We can fix her.
Guys, we can fix her.
She's like, I hate nice people.
It's time I bring this class to a close.
You can fix it.
Guys, if you want to try fixing Mori, exclamation point Nike, and the pin link in the description, in the chat.
And click my link, and you too can fix her.
It helps me and the stream a lot.
Can you fix her though?
You too can also try and fix her.
Oh my god, we did it.
We can play Bubble March.
I'm curious.
Everyone's saying Bubble March is a really cute game too.
Oh, it came from inside her.
To cover this entire space would be impossible.
I used the bubbles I had available to create this tree.
Wait, she created the tree?
The tree's made of bubbles?
And redirects it into the bubbles.
Which increases their surface area.
Wow.
So when you call this the bubble tree, you mean it's literally made of bubbles?
Oh my god, and then like...
Oh wait, they can change...
We can pop the tree!
I've never seen anything like this before.
How extraordinary.
Dude, think of that Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Can I touch it just once?
Doki-do.
Thanks.
What's wrong with me?
I mean, a bubble is meant to be popped.
That's surprising.
I thought it would be cold since it's made out of...
Yeah.
That's what I thought too.
That's interesting.
I want to check something.
Siren.
Excuse me for a moment.
She can just make more tree bubbles.
She can make another bubble tree.
In order to exchange senses with the tree, she activates her ability.
The warmth of the water travels up the trunk of the tree and reaches the massive membrane that touches the ocean, the frigid touch of ocean water, and a sensation like something is watching from beyond.
What's she doing?
Is she merging with the tree?
No, you can't.
If you keep going, it'll be dangerous.
Wait, why?
What do you mean?
Yeah.
Huh?
We'd have no way of fighting.
Then you would never be able to return to the surface.
The war monster?
But he's outside.
What is this thing you're talking about?
We're in him.
How can he come get us?
Something dangerous that doesn't understand language.
Were you hiding here from that thing too?
Yes.
I quickly realized that my ability had no effect on it.
He has a manifestation of himself.
It's like white blood cells.
Oh, it's his white blood cells.
That's right.
Nice people don't exist in the Nikkei world.
But I am curious.
It's not programmed.
We live in an area where people don't stick to an exit for others without good reason.
We're not used to people being kind simply for the sake of being kind.
So, you can understand why I'm somewhat intrigued.
Why are you going so far out of your way to help us?
Why are you not more wary of us, a bunch of strangers?
Why are you not scared of us, a bunch of strangers?
Who are you waiting for?
Maybe you Maybe you're not confident.
Maybe you're being this nice because of some hidden motive.
Or something.
She doesn't understand.
You're arriving here felt like a divine gift.
I've been here on my own for so long.
She's so lonely.
She just wants to talk to people.
I had the chance to talk to someone again felt like a gift.
So I wanted to help you in any way possible and be nice to you.
This hasn't had communication with people in so long.
Here, I'll show you.
How?
She has a phone on?
Her phone still works?
So much time has passed already.
If that date on the screen is correct, then I believe it's been about 70 years.
Jesus Christ, she had not talked to anybody.
And then Mori was like, you get lonely?
What a bitch.
Like, what the fuck?
No wonder you considered us a gift from above.
That would also explain why you've been so benevolent toward us.
I have to say, Sirenix, you seem like a real hard luck case.
Wait, so she's an older model.
Wait, why is the older model stronger than every other Nike?
You don't make them like they used to, guys.
It's like...
It's like when you have, like, the iPhone 1 is more sturdier than the newer iPhones.
Some day, you can tell your story.
All of it.
We've experienced our fair share of hardships, too.
So no matter what your story is, we'll be able to handle it.
Oh, they lost the tech to make these types of models?
Oh!
That's interesting.
That makes sense.
They lost, like...
They lost the patent to make these models, too.
Why do you keep coming here and pestering me?
Oh?
Don't you remember what I said?
I told you to drop the whole saint act.
Boy, stop being such a bitch!
You insist on coming back here again and again.
By the way, you can get it for free right now during the anniversary.
Don't laugh.
I'll leave soon.
Don't think that I'm gonna start opening up to you because of this.
So if you like...
You are real lucky, do you know that?
If you like a tsundere in your team right now...
If you wanna fix her right now, you can get her for free!
By using my link!
That's pinned in chat!
Good segue, Doki.
Good job.
It's like when Obama gave himself a medal.
That's me right now.
Yeah, if you do an exclamation point, Nike...
You can...
Click on the link below.
You can get up to 160 free points.
And...
Mori!
For free!
And you can fix it!
Emails with Somi...
Cool!
She's not happy.
Is that...
What I think it is?
Where did you find it?
Near the submarine.
Are you hungry?
I can't believe you found something like that over there.
I...
I guess so.
Would you like to go together later?
I...
I guess so.
Did he just...
Reuse that voice line?
Good night, Mori!
Hmm...
Oh, it's like every day she's like...
Trusting people more and more.
Another week passes.
Is there anything else to look through?
Stop wearing suit boxes and steps outside.
Oh, she's like opening up herself more and more.
Huh?
Streaks of silvery liquid flow and undulate like a galaxy.
What's got you so mesmerized?
Yeah.
Don't sneak up on me like that.
Wow.
I've never seen ocean water that color.
It's like...
The Ouro Borealis.
Right here?
In this bubble...
In the bubble tree?
All located in...
Little Mermaid's bubble sphere?
Can't see it?
I'm trying to look like that's here inside your bubble.
Why do you look so worried?
Is that stuff over there bad?
Everyone!
Inside!
Oh no, is that...
Oh my god, it's the evil Ouro Borealis!
What's that red light?
Yeah, what is it?
Raptures?
They're coming this way!
Borealis Borealis!
Since when can raptures move underwater?
From what I know...
Aurora Borealis...
...are incapable of that.
Oh...
Siren...
What is this place?
Are we really in the ocean?
Oh...
Oh no...
Well...
If you guys wanna find out more...
Exclamation point neat game...
And you can download the game yourself...
To know more about the current story...
Cause now...
Now is...
Bubble time!
Time!
It's time!
I can finally play the mini game!
It makes me happy!
Alright...
Cool, cool!
Uni looks at Mihara who is sleeping sadly under the bubble tree.
I wanna play the bubble game!
Cool!
Uni?
Cool?
What are you doing here alone?
Where is Mihara?
Oh wait, I have to read this myself now.
No mermaid probably spots Mihara who is fast asleep.
So you're on your own because Mihara is sleeping!
Cool, cool!
Are you feeling bored?
Cool, cool, cool!
Then would you like to play a board game with me?
Oh!
Cool, cool, cool, cool!
Guys, I sound just like her!
Ape taught me how to make these!
Not only did they help me learn how to control the bubbles better!
But they are also a great way to pass the time when you're bored!
Would you like me to teach you?
Cool...
Uni looks down at her body, bound in restraints.
It's okay!
We can work together!
You tell me where to put the parts, and I'll move them for you!
Cool!
Why don't you and I give it a shot then?
Ooh!
All right!
Oh!
All right, let's see what the minigame is supposed to be.
What's this?
Oh!
Bubblemar...
Oh, wait!
Is this like...
Like, Siege type?
Oh, is this a Siege game?
Uh, created using minions and rapture advance for a destroyer...
Yeah!
Went by protecting the allies tower and destroyer...
Okay, wait, I know this type of game!
Um...
Start battle...
Yeah, it's like...
Summon heroes and minions to fight against...
Invade...
Yeah, it's like...
Cool!
So I have to wait, because I don't have money right now.
Yeah, it is!
Okay, we'll send...
Can you select...
Minions?
Uh...
Summon!
Wait...
Oh, oh, oh!
Guys!
Um...
I'm tapping!
Oh, I have to tapping!
Sorry...
I figured it out!
It's okay!
It's okay, my tower is okay!
I, sorry...
I got a little silly there...
I got a little silly, guys.
Just a little silly...
Just a little...
I got a little silly!
Wait, I can almost have 300!
Just a little silly, guys.
Okay.
Alright, don't worry.
A big buddy is coming in.
We did it!
Oh, so it's like the siege.
It's basically like siege.
Oh, wait, I can be in a union?
Guys, I can't jump.
There's a union.
Oh my god.
Guys, I can join a union.
Alright.
How do I join a union?
You're currently not in a union.
We can finally... Guys, we can have a union.
Oh, I didn't... Oh, we can research.
We have to research.
Okay, I want to upgrade gunner.
We should upgrade guns.
Alright.
Um, and then... Oh, so there's normal difficulty.
It's time to unionize.
Guys.
Dude, they have tensile.
Wait, I want to claim all of this.
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's do it.
Let's do easy two.
Alright.
Summon bubbles can be used to enhance, upgrade level... The higher the level, the more powerful.
Okay.
Okay, I can upgrade now.
Oh, I forgot to claim them.
No!
My union!
How am I supposed to afford... How am I supposed to start a union if I forget?
Oh, I can make bubbles.
Oh no, they have gunners now.
Oh... Oh...
Wait, don't worry.
I have guns, too.
Who's... What's this?
Bubble Bomber Man.
Oh!
Wait, I want healers.
Okay.
Go heal.
Um...
I want to save up for a big gun.
Okay, big gun.
Go in there.
Don't worry.
You're healing.
I'm healing you.
Oh no, I'm...
I'm not doing so well.
Um...
Oh, these guys...
These guys are a lot better.
Um...
Upgrade.
He should be a little stronger now, right?
It's okay.
I'll save up for...
Big boy.
Okay, um...
I'm not very good at this.
I just realized...
Oh, this is bad.
This is...
Okay.
You know what?
You know what's gonna help me?
Big boy.
That's fine.
It's big boy time.
He can't fail me.
She can't fail me.
Look at that.
Look at her go.
She's about to die.
Oh.
Okay, let me like...
Okay.
Here you go.
Can't be that bad.
Okay, I figured it out.
I'm like...
I didn't think she'd die that fast, guys.
It's okay.
I figured it out.
Look at that.
There you go.
We're winning.
We did it.
Nice.
See, guys?
I told you.
Wait, there's a timer?
Oh my god.
Oh.
That's okay.
We can do this.
I believe in this.
Oh, this seems really fun.
Definitely like pretty addicting.
I feel like...
I feel like this can get really, really addicting.
I want to join...
I want to join a union.
Let me in.
Why won't they let me unionize?
I think this game mode seems to be really, really fun.
And so that people can get addicted to just this part of the game mode.
But yeah.
It was nice to check it out.
Why don't we go check on the bubble tree?
Wait, can I defeat this challenge?
Wait.
Alright.
How strong is this?
Are they?
Wait, can I use them?
Oh, no.
They're fixed at level three?
It's okay.
I have her.
One.
Two.
Three.
Okay.
That should be like the strongest, right?
Alright, how do I...
You think I can do it?
I think I can do this.
Alright.
I should be...
I would be surprised if you lose this.
I would be too.
Alright.
There's no way.
Can't be that hard.
Wait, that's not her.
Wait, okay.
There you go.
Where do I shoot, though?
Oh, wait.
See?
Look at that.
Aim.
Okay, now shoot the head.
Wait, it's so easy.
This is not a cha...
Oh, wait.
He has more HP.
Wait.
That's it.
It's so easy.
Just shoot the head.
Oh, shit.
My burst.
I was so good that I forgot about my other abilities.
For class to begin.
Class in Wonderland!
Pay attention in class.
Jesus.
I did it!
I did it, guys.
Look at that.
See?
It's just that easy.
Look at that.
Clear the first stage.
Fastest clear of my life.
Alright.
Now we can leave.
This place used to be so quiet.
But now it's bustling with noise.
Yay!
Well, that was fun.
That was fun to check out...
Um...
To look through Nikkei again during all the new updates.
Oh, we guys had a great time looking at the new updates for the 2.5 anniversary!
Anniversary!
Guys.
Um...
As you guys know...
Uh...
We did not...
We didn't complete the story.
Uh...
And...
Wait, there's a union?
Wait, before...
Wait, actually, let me join the union real quick.
This is very important.
Where's the union?
Alright.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, there it is!
Oh!
We will be the...
Wait, can I create a union?
Oh my god, I can create...
Uh...
Wait, I don't have money!
No!
I don't have money to create a union!
Wait, we can...
Let's...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
There has to be...
Welcome back.
Wait a minute.
Maybe...
Maybe I'll have just enough money, guys.
Guys, maybe there's just enough money in here.
We can...
We can scavenge some money real quick.
Wait...
Guys, we have to create...
No.
There has to be...
What did I get?
What are these?
I got the... gacha tickets?
Oh, I can test my luck here.
Wait.
Buckley.
No, they're not the Mario... No.
They're not the Mario tickets.
No!
There has to be something!
Guys, I'm just going through my couch right now trying to find any...
I'm going... going through my couch.
To see if we can find any remaining cash for us.
There has to be... There has to be something.
No.
There has to be gems somewhere.
We must have some gems somewhere.
Campaign Bosses 300... Guys, okay, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Okay, guys, we have to start a union before we go.
So, the union is very important.
Okay, before... We have to unionize before we go.
Wait, is the story?
Okay, we're almost done with the story.
We're almost done.
Alright.
Don't worry.
We can get... We can get it.
Alright, let's redo my team real quick, too.
Alright, we have to get rid of you.
Wait, who is my strongest?
I'm always ready.
Okay, Modernia.
Yes.
I will always protect you, Commander.
Um...
Level 4.
Little Mermaid.
Okay, one...
We need number two.
Two...
One, two, three.
Okay.
What do we keep?
I'm always ready.
There you go.
You have burst two?
What's burst two?
What do we do?
Privatey?
Here?
Is this better?
Okay.
That's fine.
Alright.
There you go.
Alright, guys.
Hey, Commander!
Skip.
It's all about the gems.
Guys.
We need...
We all...
We need just enough.
Bro!
You don't understand!
You don't...
Oh my god!
World Camp!
Pew pew pew pew pew!
Headshot!
Here you go.
It's okay.
Tell me the story of victory!
Whoa!
Oh, that's so cute!
She just won!
It's the...
Oh!
I like that.
Okay, uh...
Cinderella.
Nice.
Oh my god!
Okay, he's definitely dead.
Yeah, he's definitely dead.
Wait, he has so much HP!
How does he have so much HP?!
Okay, it's fine.
Jesus Christ, he has a lot.
Headshot.
How does he still...
He still has HP?!
Okay, we don't need her.
Alright.
Get him out of here!
Yeah, he's tanky as fuck!
Everyone!
Give him everything you've got!
Jesus!
Nice, we did it.
Is he dead?
Yay!
Alright, how far are we from completing this chapter?
How far are we?
Skip!
Wait, there's Mihara!
There's...
Guys, look!
There she is!
Look at the upgrade!
How far?
How far are we?
You don't want me to go there?
Don't keep bleeding!
Ha ha ha!
I'm sorry!
Guys, you don't...
Guys, this is important!
I want...
Guys, if you guys wanna read the lore, you can...
Extermination Point, Nikkei, and you too...
can experience the lore!
Okay.
Alright.
If you wanna know what's going on, click the link, and download the game, and you too can experience it.
Right now, we need to start...
Union is more important right now.
Nice.
The lore!
Okay, but...
Unionizing.
Alright.
How far am I?
I literally...
Wait, how much...
Guys, how much...
How much...
How many gems do I need again?
Was it 500?
Yeah, but I wanna start my own.
So I can make the walls.
I wanna start my own union.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I definitely did not have to use this yet.
Uh, fuck it, I'll use it now.
But I wanna know what she does.
Oh my god, bombardment!
Where's the...
Okay, there he is.
I was gonna say, where is the big boy?
Let me clear my throat.
Let me kill that big boy.
Where did he go?
There he is.
Jesus, they're so tanky.
I can't name it.
Don't keep it...
Don't worry.
I'll...
I'll have a better name for the...
For my union.
I've administered first...
Alright.
Let's see how...
Jesus!
They're all blocking me from my goal!
It's right here!
They're all blocking me!
I need to go there!
Wait, I'm just weak?
Don't worry, I know what to do.
Okay, I just gotta upgrade all of these people.
Okay, I won't be weak no longer.
Don't worry, give me a sec.
The moment...
The moment I upgrade...
I won't be weak no longer.
Okay, uh...
You know what, Cinderella?
Jesus, everything's dead.
I think every...
I think they're all dead.
Where is he?
Alright.
Alright, let me upgrade my Nikkei super fast.
So then we can finish these guys faster.
What a truly beautiful story this was.
Oh, nice!
Upgrading my outpost too!
Alright.
No, you don't understand.
This is important.
Alright, let's see.
Uh...
Nikkei, what am I using in my squad?
I don't remember.
Okay, we need to upgrade Nava.
Okay, let's upgrade...
Actually, can I upgrade Cinderella?
Oh...
Nice!
Now she's stronger.
Okay, Cinderella's a little stronger now.
That's good.
And then...
Okay, I can give her a little bit...
Level 31.
And then who else is in my squad?
Little Mermaid, Cinderella...
Private...
Okay, Nava, you gotta be a little stronger.
Buddy.
You can't be down here.
Okay.
Well, level 6 is something.
Level 6 is something, okay?
Level...
Levels...
At least it's something.
I...
I'll take this.
Okay.
Upgrade.
Alright, and then...
Nice.
Now you're super...
Now you're gonna be big and strong for me.
I should really...
Wait, can I upgrade the...
No, I can't.
Wait, can I?
No, they're all...
Fucking shit.
I can't.
Alright.
Who else?
Who else is in here?
Novel...
Private...
Okay.
Mermaid.
Where's Mermaid?
I think I have.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I don't have...
Yeah, they're all...
Shit.
That's all I have.
Alright, good.
I think that should be enough.
Look, we are 2k...
Stronger now.
Should I go in person?
We're 2k stronger.
It should be faster now.
Alright, where's she?
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Okay, now we should be a little faster.
Pew, pew, pew.
Pew, pew.
Pew.
It's okay.
A little...
You just got hurt a little bit.
You're strong enough for this.
You don't need cover.
You don't need defense.
Just keep fighting.
Where are they?
You don't need defense.
Just go in there.
Tell me the story of victory.
Nice.
Pew, pew.
The story will be rewritten into a tale that's happy and beautiful.
Alright, get in there.
Oh my god, there's so many of them.
Please.
Why are there so many of them?
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Believe in my team.
Do I actually have to do anything?
Oh, whoa.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
Guys.
My keys per second is so fast, guys.
I did that all naturally.
I...
Oh my god, look at that.
I did that all naturally.
I'm playing the game.
Now is the time of true beauty.
Yippee!
Yep.
She did that all herself.
Guys, I don't know what you're saying.
Auto?
What does that mean?
That's not in my gamer vocabulary.
Wait, does extra stage...
Wait, does the extra stage have...
Have gems?
Do you have gems?
Oh my god.
The puzzles will show us the way.
Yes.
This is it.
Oh my god.
This is all we needed.
This is actually all we needed.
We could do this.
We just need to kill him.
That's fine.
We don't have to...
We don't need cover.
We just need to shoot him.
Yeah!
That would be enough.
That's just enough.
Alright.
We're good to go.
Now we can leave.
Finally.
There's everything we needed, guys.
Union.
Now I can create my own union.
Alright.
Wait.
Okay, I want a different icon.
Okay, nevermind.
Um...
I guess that's my icon.
Alright.
So, my name for my union...
Is...
Wait, is that...
It has to be eight characters, right?
Not Doki.
Oh my god.
It's not Doki, guys.
They'll never know.
Oh, wait, wait.
Actually...
Wait, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven...
No!
Hahaha!
I want this...
Falls!
Hahaha!
Okay!
Wait!
That's gonna be...
That's my union name!
Hahaha!
That's...
It's such a stupid joke.
It's actually infuriating.
Alright, there we go.
That's my...
That's gonna be my union name.
Um...
Alright, here we go.
No!
Cannot be...
What's the point?
I...
Oh, I'm so sad.
I'm so sad.
I can't include...
Special symbols.
There we go.
Food...
True.
Hahaha!
How much can I...
Do this for...
Okay, food...
True.
There we go.
That's my...
That's my union name.
Food True.
You mean...
Oh, yeah.
Food...
False.
Let's do that.
Food...
False.
There we go.
Hahaha!
That's...
That's my...
That's my union name, guys.
So...
We're not giving them food.
There we go.
Free my union.
That's right.
This was my long bit.
It all...
It's all a circle, guys.
It's all a circle.
I told you...
This...
Hahahaha!
What a union...
How do I let...
Alright.
Union settings.
Entry level.
You gotta be loveful.
Hahahaha!
You gotta...
Only...
Only the real Nikkei players can join this...
Can join this...
Can join...
This union.
Hahahaha!
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Since I'm feeling...
Extra generous.
You can be level 95.
I guess...
I guess you can be level 55.
So...
I wish I could...
Alright, alright.
Level 10.
Please enter reason...
Okay.
Don't...
Feed...
The Nikkes.
Hahahaha!
Okay, there you go.
Uh...
You can send...
Mail to all...
Oh, wait.
I can?
Um...
Let's see.
Save.
Oh, I can't...
Contain...
Symbols?
Don't feed the Nikkes.
There you go.
Union settings.
Save.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I already have so many...
Applications.
Alright.
Let's see.
Union mail.
To all...
To all Nikkei owners.
Okay.
Nikkei...
On...
There.
There you go.
If you feed your Nikkei...
I kick you out.
I kick.
There you go.
So...
Nii...
Hahaha!
There you go.
Nice.
I love my union.
You are a villain and a tyrant!
The...
This is my...
I told you.
This is my union.
I get to do whatever I want.
Enter an announcement.
Drinking is not allowed either.
Okay.
Wait.
Just...
Just program them...
Better.
There you go.
Easy.
Alright.
Who...
Who is in my...
Who is in my army?
Chat...
Yeah.
Can I create more than one?
More...
Oh, I'm an NA.
Oh my god.
There's someone that's level 260.
Level 305.
Oh, I have some strong...
369.
Okay.
Nice.
My strongest...
My strongest warrior.
369.
Nice.
Alright.
That's all.
Can I have more than one union?
Okay.
I click their profiles.
Alright.
What...
Oh my god.
They're strong as hell.
No self introduction needed.
Yeah, I'm NA.
The strongest dragoon in Nikkei.
Oh my...
Wait.
They have Nier.
Can I steal her?
Ha ha ha.
Steal.
I...
Did you guys leave your...
Did you guys leave your union for my union?
Good.
Ha ha.
You're canon.
Oh sorry.
It's 2B.
I meant like it's from Nier.
I've never played Nier before guys.
It's 2B.
I just know the game is called Nier.
Oh my god guys.
Did some of you guys left your old unions to join my union?
Good.
Ha ha ha.
Alright.
Nice.
I wonder...
Can I have more than one union?
Or is it just one union?
Oh, it's just one.
That's alright.
What's this?
How do I have a stronger union guys?
Only one?
How do I have stronger unions?
Be active?
Alright.
I believe in you guys.
My male come...
I can send daily mail to my members.
Yay.
The mail.
I can actually send you guys mail.
Anyway.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let's see.
I got a couple of ones for you.
Why do I have this road for you?
I have this read to you?
So if you use the link...
Follow your link...
very big wise...
Number one.
you!
I create a account, less like the link, next on channel, straight away.
In an hour, you'll get a new mail from your leader.
Link in bio.
I hope.
Anyway.
Anyway, guys.
Well, that was fun.
That was fun.
Thank you again to...
Thank you again to Nikkei for sponsoring me today.
I had a lot of fun.
I streamed a lot longer than my supposed times.
But, like, I did have a lot of fun playing the game.
That's why I streamed a lot longer than what I was supposed to.
But, yes.
Huge shout out to Nikkei again for sponsoring me.
If you guys want to check out the game yourself and want to know more about the story, more about the characters.
Or try to see if you can pull Little Mermaid.
You can click on the link if you do exclamation point Nikkei.
Or just click the link that's pinned in the chat.
But, yeah.
Thank you, everybody.
I had a great time.
I hope you guys had a great time as well.
I'm gonna call it here right now.
For those who are new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube.
Today, I'm on Twitch because my sponsor was on Twitch.
I do have another sponsor tomorrow.
So, please check that out as well tomorrow.
And support that stream as well.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause your check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flow.
And if you step for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!